just relax today's a great day to be
outside and just save some time for
yourself we'll have sunny skies
those winds are going to be so much
lighter than yesterday in fact there's
nothing going on out there look at the
beautiful snow that's still in our
mountains we had a little snow up there
yesterday haven't seen anything official
but it was flying up there at lee canyon
i was watching the flakes as that system
just kind of rushed through with that
cold front good air quality today all
across the board so that's always good
news you can breathe easier outside it
is cool this morning grab a jacket or
sweater for the kiddos before they head
out for school get one for yourself
we're looking at mid 40s in a lot of
neighborhoods still close to 50 up at
aliante 53 downtown 50 in green valley
this morning 49 in henderson 36 out at
red rock and we've got a lot of temps
below freezing once you get north of las
vegas and clark county 29 in caliani
look at the 30s up there reno's below
freezing 58 right now death valley 38 in
indian springs low 40's for trump right
now and 54 in laughlin with 50 in
boulder city it is going to be a cooler
day that cold fronts to the east of us
and there's another one right there off
the west coast that low pressure still
spinning some snow and some rain showers
now moving out of utah up into wyoming
today so that's where the winter-like
weather will be this was a cold system
really hit mid 60's yesterday so
heather's winter chill her cold chill
was very warranted yesterday 70 degrees
today with sunshine light winds should
feel a lot better very fall like days
here as we finish off the week but those
systems will we'll see waves coming into
the west over the rest of the week and
that's going to drag some clouds our way
at times we've got a full moon this week
so we don't want clouds in the night sky
i want to be able to see that big
hunter's moon it is going to be
beautiful but we will get clouds off and
on all through the week 81 on friday
will be our warmest day a stronger
system moves in late sunday into monday
brings more wind and a chance of showers
again to the desert